do Orthodox Christians from that area do
they know and that was our lack of
educating do they know that we as
Muslims love Jesus do they know that we
believe in her mighty messenger do they
know that their there are so many
commonalities between us uh yeah I doubt
it because even you doubt that they know
that I I doubt they know that maybe some
maybe there are priests probably know
that but they don't teach them about it
yeah because it's not in their interest
okay they will probably lose the job
yeah so I mean even many Muslims in
Bosnia don't know that you know if you
mention Jesus it's like wow you know you
know it's like and they don't realize
that Jesus was just another great
prophet of God you know and and that he
was also a Muslim and teaching Islam and
teaching message of submitting your will
to the will of God the whole prophets
were teaching same message and and
submitting your will to the will of God
you went translated in arabic is means
islam that's all it is right you know
yes so you know so and you cannot be a
muslim unless you believe in all
prophets of God including Jesus you know
yeah you can't be or if Muslims are
learning their faith okay and practicing
their faith and then teaching others
non-muslims you know that we love Jesus
maybe the relationship would be better
with other non-muslim people mm-hmm
because they will realize hey they also
Revere respect and love Jesus just like
we you know yeah we just don't worship
Him as a god or literal son of God right
because jesus never called people to
worship himself but he called people to
worship God